[Musique]
m
durant la crise qu vide en fait les deux
sociétés avaient commencé à travailler
ensemble en fait sur une thématique de
coussins gonflables à usages médicaux
lorsqu'emmanuel fievet le fondateur de
deir captifs c'est s'est manifestée
commettre comme étant vendeurs de sa
société de sa start up les pourparlers
se sont engagés durant l'année 2021
[Musique]
le groupe michelin va apporter à air
captifs une capacité d'industrialisation
le groupe michelin a développé de
l'innovation dans le domaine des
composites flexible par son expérience
dans le pneumatique et va apporter cette
compétence en particulier dans les
textiles techniques air captifs apporte
à michelin un premier ancrage qui va
permettre de de croître et de réaliser
davantage de chiffre d'affaires dans un
domaine au delà du pneumatique
[Musique]
on